>>> I DON'T GO, HEY!
I GO, HEY.
DEEPER VOICE.
>> HEY!
>> HE BECAME AN ICON AS THE FONZ
IN "HAPPY DAYS."
THESE DAYS HENRY WINKLER HE IS
BEING HAILED FOR THE HIT HBO
SERIES "BARRY" IN THE FOURTH AND
FINAL SEASON.
IT FOLLOWS THE STORY OF A HITMAN
WHO FINDS HIMSELF IN THE LOS
ANGELES ACTING SCENE.
WINKLER PLAYS BARRY'S ACTING
TEACHER IN THE SHOW.
[ PHONE RINGING ]
>> YES?
>> I GOT TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
MOUNTAIN AND MY CELL LEAPT TO
LIFE.
>> CAN'T YOU JUST SAY I GOT
SERVICE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE?
>> BARRY ESCAPED FROM PRISON.
IT HAPPENED SOMETIME LATE
YESTERDAY.
>> HE KNOWS WHERE THIS PLACE IS.
>> I HIGHLY DOUBT HE WOULD BE
GOING TO BIG BEAR.
YOU ARE ON THE TOP OF A
MOUNTAIN.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO COME GET ME.
>> BRING YOU BACK TO L.A.?
NO, NO.
LISTEN, I JUST SPOKE WITH THE
D.A. AND HE SAID IT WAS A
FORTUNATE EVENT THAT YOU ARE
SEQUESTERED UP THERE.
>> I AM A SITTING [ BLEEP ]
DUCK, TOM!
>> HENRY WINKLER IS HERE WITH US
NOW.
CLEARLY, AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
CLIP, THE SHOW HAS SOME REAL
DRAMA TO IT.
>> IT DOES.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHERE THE SHOW IS
GOING TO GO.
>> YEAH.
>> WE ARE ALL INSIDE BILL
HADER'S MIND.
THAT IS -- AND AS LONG AS YOU
ARE COMFORTABLE, AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE PACKED FOR TWO WEEKS, YOU
ARE FINE.
>> ARE YOU COMFORTABLE BEING IN
BILL HADER'S MIND?
>> I AM.
THE MAN IS A GENIUS.
WE HAVE TWO CREATORS.
ALEC BERG, THE CREME DE LA CREME
OF COMEDY WRITING.
BILL HADER, WHO WANTED TO BE A
DIRECTOR, DIVERTED HIS LIFE TO
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE," CAME BACK
TO WHAT HE SHOULD BE DOING.
>> YOU'RE AN ACTING TEACHER?
>> I AM.
>> IN THE SHOW.
HOW DID YOU -- I MEAN, I ASSUME
YOU HAVE BEEN IN FRONT OF ACTING
TEACHERS BEFORE IN YOUR LIFE.
>> 14.
>> I HAD 14 --
>>
I HAD 14 TEACHERS.
YOU TAKE THE NOTES THAT ALEC
BERG'S WIFE WHEN THEY WERE IN
CLASS, WHICH THEY BASED HIM ON,
YOU PUSH IT IN AND SPIT IT OUT.
>> HOW DOES IT COME ACROSS, DO
YOU THINK?
>> I HAVE FUN.
I THINK -- BILL SAID TO THEM
HALFWAY THROUGH THE FIRST YEAR,
OH, HE'S AN [ BLEEP ].
>> HALFWAY THROUGH THE YEAR?
>> YES.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW.
I JUST THOUGHT HE WAS, LIKE,
THOUGHTLESS.
>> IF PEOPLE ARE NOT WATCHING
"BARRY" PEOPLE WHO KNOW YOU AS
THE FONZ AND SEE YOUR ROLE AS AN
ACTOR THINK YOU WERE KNOWN YOU
WERE DESTINED FOR SUCCESS.
DID YOU ALWAYS KNOW THIS WAS
YOUR LIFE'S WORK?
>> I KNEW I WANTED IT TO BE MY
LIFE'S WORK.
I DIDN'T KNOW IT WOULD TURN OUT
TO BE SO WONDERFUL AND SO
VARIED.
THERE WERE PERIODS WHEN NOTHING
HAPPENED FOR EIGHT OR NINE
YEARS.
AND THEN I REINVENTED MYSELF.
>> YOU'VE BEEN SUCH A MAINSTAY
ON PEOPLE'S SCREENS FOR SO LONG.
WE WERE TALKING BEFORE WE SAT
DOWN ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IN THIS
MOMENT IN 2023.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE APPROACHING AN
ELECTION SEASON, A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
GIVEN THE ROLES THAT YOU PLAY,
HOW DO YOU SEE WHERE WE ARE NOW?
>> I SEE WHERE WE ARE NOW -- MY
THOUGHT IS IMAGINE A
CATASTROPHE, A NATURAL
CATASTROPHE, WHICH WE HAVE NOW
EXPERIENCED A LOT OF.
HUMAN BEINGS ARE ON THEIR ROOF.
EVERYTHING THAT THEY OWN IS
UNDERNEATH AND DESTROYED
UNDERNEATH THE ROOF.
A BOAT IS COMING.
DO YOU SAY WHAT IS YOUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION?
WHOA!
YOU'RE -- THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
PARTY FOR ME.
TURN THE BOAT AROUND.
OR DO YOU SAY, I NEED YOU, SAVE
ME.
WE NEED EACH OTHER.
WHAT THE HELL ARE WE DOING?
>> DO YOU THINK WE'VE LOST THAT?
>> I THINK WE BETTER LISTEN TO
EACH OTHER AND THIS -- THIS KIND
OF MICRO CUTTING OURSELVES INTO
SHREDS AND SEPARATING OURSELVES
LIKE BY AN OCEAN IS INSANE AND
UNTENABLE.
BUT THAT'S ONLY A THOUGHT.
>> ONE THING YOU SAID THAT I
LOVED, YOU SAID ONE OF THE BEST
GIFTS YOUR MARRIAGE BROUGHT YOU
WAS YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW.
>> YES, THAT'S TRUE.
>> YOU HAVE AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
YOU WANTED TO SHARE TODAY ABOUT
HIM.
>> I WAS INVITED BY SOMEONE WHO
WAS WITH iCEYE CARE, EYE HEALTH.
MY FATHER-IN-LAW WAS A ROBUST,
SIX-FOOT DENTIST.
FUNNY.
JUST A WONDERFUL MAN WHO
ACCEPTED ME AS HENRY.
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT WHAT I DID.
IT WAS DIFFERENT THAN MY OWN
FAMILY.
SLOWLY I WATCHED HIS SIGHT
DISINTEGRATE.
HE HAD AGE-RELATED MACULAR
DEGENERATION, WHICH THEN CAN
PROCEED TO THIS IS -- GEOGRAPHIC
ATROPHY, WHICH IS INCURABLE.
SO THERE IS A WEBSITE CALLED
GA -- GEOGRAPHIC ATROPHY WON'T
WAIT.
GA WON'T WAIT.
I SAY NEITHER SHOULD YOU.
GET YOUR EYES CHECKED NOW.
YOU CAN'T SCREW AROUND WITH
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING ON T